now we reach the dreaded point in every
game development cycle where we have to
start worrying about performance now for
a small map the code we have will work
perfectly well but for a large maps we
quickly incur significant overhead this
makes sense since what we're actually
doing is drawing the entire map every
single frame regardless of what's
actually visible to the canvas instead
of this let's only draw the tiles that
are on the screen at any given time this
saves considerably on the total number
of draw calls per frame that are done
which is typically where the bottlenecks
are in high performance applications now
to implement this notice that we've
added a new view rect object within our
tiled map class this object represents
the coordinates as well as width and
height of our visible canvas to take
advantage of this we have to modify our
drawing function slightly first we'll
need to check our world X and world Y
values against the current view rect
position and size and stop processing
that tile if it's outside of our view
rect next we have to modify our world X
and worldwide coordinates they take into
account the view rectangle offset
ensuring that the X&Y value that they
passed to draw image our canvas oriented
rather than world oriented